bienvenidos a la presentación de
multiplicación de fracciones esta vez
estará realmente feliz porque estamos
frente a algo que multiplicarlo es más
fácil que sumarlo o restarlo y si no me
lo crees vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
muy bien así que iniciemos empezaremos
con hagamos este un medio por un medio
cuando multiplicamos fracciones es algo
muy directo básicamente se reduce a dos
multiplicaciones esto es multiplicamos
los numeradores o sea uno por uno y los
denominadores o sea dos por dos esto es
igual a un cuarto así un medio por un
medio es igual a un cuarto lo cual hace
sentido es decir la mitad de un medio es
un cuarto
y qué pasa si tenemos fracciones
negativas
o sea un medio multiplicado por un medio
negativo
y tenemos una fracción negativa a mí me
gusta poner el signo negativo en el
numerador así menos 1 sobre 2
espero que esto haya sentido por lo que
tenemos 1 x menos 1 dividido entre 2 por
2 que nos da menos 1 sobre 4 que es lo
mismo que menos un cuarto
y qué pasa cuando tengo diferentes
denominadores cuando sumas o restas
fracciones aquí las cosas se ponen
difíciles pero este no es el caso
si tengo dos tercios por un medio
multiplicamos los numeradores dos por
uno y los denominadores tres por dos y
esto es igual a dos por uno es 2 3 por 2
es 6
dos sextos lo que podemos escribir como
la fracción un tercio este ejemplo es
muy interesante y se presta para mostrar
este truco así que volvamos a hacerlo
dos tercios por un medio como en
cualquier problema ya dijimos hay que
multiplicar los numeradores y los
denominadores y obtenemos la respuesta
pero algunas veces hay este pequeño
truco que podemos decir puedes cancelar
como en el caso que está multiplicando y
dividiendo por lo mismo o sea 2 por 1
entre 3 por 2 lo que es lo mismo
reordenando los términos que es 1 por 2
entre 3 por 2 lo único que hice fue
reordenar el numerador y no importa el
orden
que es equivalente a un tercio
multiplicado por 2 sobre 2 que solo es
un tercio por 1 que es igual a un tercio
lo único que hice fue reordenar los dos
porque todo el tiempo están presentes y
tenemos un 2 en el numerador y otro en
el denominador lo que quiero hacer y es
una especie de truco para hacer
multiplicaciones con rapidez y tampoco
tener que reducir el resultado demasiado
es tengo dos tercios por un tercio digo
perdón un medio hay un 2 en el numerador
y también en el denominador a los dos
los divido entre 2 y esto es un tercio
bueno espero no estar haciendo esto muy
complicado y vamos a hacer otros
ejercicios qué tal si ahora tengo 3
séptimos x dos quintos multiplicó los
numeradores 3 por 2 es 6 y los
denominadores 7 por 5 es 35
y eso es todo qué tal si ahora tengo
algunos números negativos digamos menos
tres cuartos x 211 a vos lo que es igual
a menos 6 entre 44 que es lo mismo que 3
negativo sobre 22 ahora
hagámoslo aplicando el truco esto es
menos tres cuartos multiplicado por dos
onceavos y observamos que este numerador
y este denominador son divisibles entre
2 lo que resulta en menos 3 sobre 22 es
decir menos 3 por 1 es igual a menos 32
por 11 es igual a 22 hagamos uno rápido
por aquí si tengo menos dos quintos x
menos dos quintos esto es igual
bueno menos dos por menos dos es cuatro
y cinco por cinco es 25 y nos sirve para
recordar que la multiplicación de dos
números negativos nos da un positivo
hagamos algunos ejemplos más pero tengo
la impresión que en este momento ya te
diste cuenta que la multiplicación de
fracciones es mucho más fácil que la
suma y la resta bueno estoy seguro que
no tienes problemas con las demás
operaciones no estoy pensando en los
ejercicios y ahora hagamos dos novenos
que multiplica a 18 medios tenemos un 2
en el numerador y otro en el denominador
que al dividirlos entre 2 se convierten
en 1
y tenemos un 18 en el numerador y un 9
en el denominador ambos divisibles entre
9 así que al dividirlos el 9 se
convierte en 1 y el 18 en un 2 así que
tenemos 1 por 2 dividido entre 1 por 1
que es igual a 2 entre 1 estos que lo
podríamos haber hecho también por el
camino largo esto es 2 novenos por 18
medios
que es igual a 2 por 18 36 y 9 por 2 es
18 resulta 36 18 ambos el 18 cabe dos
veces en el 36 o sea que otra vez
tenemos 2 cualquiera de estos caminos es
bueno pero si no te sientes cómodo con
esta técnica no es necesario que lo
realices el objetivo es no terminar con
unos números grandes cuando haces las
multiplicaciones y después tener que
simplificar hagamos más ejemplos digamos
que sean dos menos cinco o séptimos por
un tercio es igual a menos 5 por 1 menos
57 por 33 21 y eso es todo ahora hagamos
otro con este truco que ya utilizamos y
digamos que
15 entre aquí verás que útil es el truco
entre 21 por 14 entre 5 es claro que si
multiplicamos terminaremos con unos
números muy grandes pero con un poco de
atención observamos que tenemos un 15 y
un 5 los cuales son divisibles entre 5
así que 15 dividido entre 5 resulta 3 y
5 dividido entre 5 resulta 1 14 y 21 son
divisibles entre 7 así que 14 entre 7
resultados y 21 entre 7 resulta 3 por lo
que tenemos 3 por 26 dividido entre 3
por 1 que es 3
igual a 2 haciéndolo de otra manera
sería 15 por 14 que nos da 210 y estaría
dividido entre 21 por 5 es 105 y en este
caso se ve obvio que también resulta en
dos bueno la verdad espero no haberte
confundido con el último ejercicio lo
que vimos para la multiplicación de
fracciones es que multiplicamos los
numeradores y multiplicamos los
denominadores y después se trata sólo de
reducir con esto estás listo para
practicar las multiplicaciones y espero
que te diviertas